more isn't better only better is better
and so sometimes more is better I'm
thinking about one of the things we're
gonna talk about we could talk about an
Alex I have several more donations to
this food co-op is better yeah yeah um
yeah I mean yes sometimes more is better
for sure yes sometimes more sacks is
better sometimes more sex is too much
right and so I've been on both ends of
that spectrum comment redacted I'm
thinking so one of my my added values
later on is a Drake's new album which is
called scorpion Drizzy yeah he's got 25
songs on it and that's been the big
complaint from everyone but for me it's
like okay I don't like all 25 songs in
this um but I'm really glad he with 25
songs on here because I think the songs
that people really like the singles or
the ones I don't like and so I can kind
of make my own version like I can make a
great 15 song version of scorpion if it
is like masterpiece level good in this
case it was one of those rarities where
more was better in this case now now I
think what when Nick is saying here is
something different like hey should I
spend more money on this thing if I
can't afford it well what do you mean by
afford is so so if you can't afford it
spending more uh more money is probably
the wrong thing but if you can't afford
it then spending more today will often
save you money in the long run right
Ryan so if if the the pair of pants cost
you $100 but they're gonna last you for
two years
that's better than buying ten pairs of
$10 pants that are gonna last you one
month each you begin by the way you
don't even like them anyway right yeah
no I think about uh I learned that with
my my like shaver I bought a while ago
uh-huh like just the trimmer yeah cuz
they got like you know $8 trimmers well
that was good the $1 trimmer
yeah and replace the three months later
right yeah costing you more when you do
that right so I have this really short
blog post from Seth Godin that his
question reminded me
it's called the shortcut crowd he said
there is no market there are markets and
markets have segments there are people
who enjoy buying expensive wine there
are people who will save up their money
to have a big wedding there are people
who pay to have a personal trainer and
with within segments there are careful
consumers traditional consumers
consumers who seek out the cutting edge
there are bargain hunters luxury snobs
and people who measure the way Consumer
Reports does often overlooked though is
the fact that in many markets
particularly involving personal finance
small business and relationships there
are people who are obsessed with the
short cut they want something that's too
good to be true they respond to big
promises that offer magical nearly
instant results they want as they want a
squeeze page a trip wire offer a hard
sell they respond to these messages
because they're a signal that a short
cut is on offer my grandmother this is
the part that really stood out to me
Ryan because I bought a exercise bike
recently my Gretton I'll explain why in
a moment it actually saved me money so
we'll get to that my grandmother who
never exercised a day in her life bought
an exercise machine from a late-night TV
commercial when it's at gathering dust
she explained that she thought it would
do the exercise for her and was
disappointed that it didn't magically
make her fit for $99 so it goes on we'll
put a link to that because it's a it's a
longer essay than that I don't want to
read the whole thing but the part that
stood out to me there Ryan was like yeah
just buying the thing doesn't mean it's
gonna improve your life Bex and I have
been for about two months considering
buying an exercise bike and it's a it's
an expensive purchase but we've been
spending a decent amount of money
SoulCycle and not even going every
single day like going once a week or
sometimes it max twice a week and that
that starts to add up pretty quickly and
also I don't have the convenience of
being able to do it in my own house and
by the way solar cycle classes usually
our long and I in you pack half an hour
on each side though you know get their
shower and everything else also there's
two two and a half hour commitment to
the doing this exercise class that
becomes a barrier from you it was like
okay what if I want to do twenty or
thirty minutes of cardio
this is a great way for me for me to do
that and so be Noah justify we're
actually going to spend less money over
the long run even though I'm gonna have
to spend or I had to spend a Backson I'd
it's been a good chunk of money right
now in order to buy and exercise bike
and you didn't just buy a $99 late night
commercial exercise bike I am hoping it
does the exercises for me though that'd
be great
that's what he paid more money for my
shoes by the way remember those like
those infomercial the electric shocks
you put on your abs we're gonna work
your abs while you're watching TV yeah
dude too good to be true
yes indeed my short answer is this
forsaking your budget is more harmful
than forsaking quality so yeah of course
if you can afford a quality item get the
quality item but if you gotta go into
debt to get the quality item that is the
wrong reason to get the quality item
yeah a good example is like this pair of
pants I'm wearing they were like a
hundred bucks yeah and someone came to
like man I really like this pants did
you find Diners Club Card yes I did well
what's the brand you know we're gonna
get him and I told him and then they
shot me a text and they're like you know
I looked him up it's a little bit
outside of my budget do you know are
there any other sports brands that you
would recommend that maybe would have a
cheaper option so forth and so on yes
like this is this is the pair of pants I
really like um I feel good in them
they're comfortable they're great I can
afford them I don't have to put him up
put him on my Diners Club Card and my
friend who would have to put it on a
diners club car but they quickly realize
like oh yeah these are a good pair of
pants but I'm not gonna go out of my way
just to get a pair of pants that Ryan
has because Ryan has them and I'm
certainly not gonna go into debt to get
those pair of pants I think that is the
question that we need to be asking Nick
it's not about you know always buying
the better quality item you've got to
have room for it in your budget and the
other thing too is like how much is it
gonna cost you outside
of like you said outside of the money I
mean do you have you have time to take
care of it do you have time to
appreciate it you have time to to change
the oil and the thing whatever it may be
there are a lot of costs to consider but
just to sit there and look at quality
versus quantity quantity yes that's an
important factor but I think there are a
lot of other things we need to consider
before making a purchase just over you
know quality versus quantity
you